threatening Internet posts made by the
Florida shooting suspect put a spotlight
on the role social media companies could
play in preventing tragedies a YouTube
user says he contacted the FBI and
YouTube in September when Nicholas Cruz
apparently commented on a video saying
I'm going to be a professional school
shooter the FBI says it investigated but
was unable to identify the person behind
the post YouTube removed it Cruz also
posted several images of weapons on
Instagram an Instagram spokesperson said
quote there is absolutely no place on
our platforms for people who commit such
Miranda saks we have found and
immediately deleted the shooters account
on Facebook and Instagram YouTube
referred us to their policy Center it
says the platform can disclose user
information to law enforcement if they
believe doing so could prevent death for
physical harm CBS News contributor and
Nicholas Thompson editor-in-chief is
editor-in-chief of Wired he joins us
from San Francisco good morning Nick so
what more what more could these
platforms be doing well they could have
a they could have a serie series of
policies that help more in these cases
you could have a much closer
relationship between the social media
platforms and law enforcement they could
make it much easier for law enforcement
to get information they could hire many
more people to monitor these platforms
for threats like that that they could
send on but at the same time they also
have to protect you and user privacy so
there are complicated trade-offs and
they also have to protect free speech so
the complicated trade-offs here
Instagram has put itself in one place
Google has put itself in another place
but there is more they could do but it's
tough now that the the disturbing
comment where he said I want to be a
school shooter was in fact reported to
the FBI the FBI says it did investigate
but they could not positively identify
the origin or the genesis of that
comment how difficult is it Nick to to
source these things out well one of the
really interesting questions here is
whether they were not able to figure it
out because the comment had already been
deleted on YouTube because it had been
reported and one of the first things
YouTube does is they delete stuff that
they see threatening or that can cause
harm that's their general policy
so happy cuz it was deleted that may
have made it or had it been deleted
before the FBI began their investigation
that would have made it harder on the
other hand it appears as though Nicholas
Cruz used his real name if indeed that
was Nicholas Cruz the other confounding
factor here is that there are tons of
threatening posts made on social media
so the real burden is on the FBI to say
okay is this a real threat can we tie
this to other accounts can we Google the
person's name and see if there's other
information there so what we don't know
is whether the system kind of broke down
on the FBI's end because they didn't
find information they should have found
whether the system broke down kind of on
youtubes end because they deleted the
comment and weren't forthcoming with the
FBI well here's the question we had this
morning talking about this how many
people are on their Instagram account
like he was posing with a bunch of guns
saying that he wanted to commit violence
and how is that that's legal the
Internet company should censor that
report that where's the responsibility
and how common is it yeah it is
unfortunately common Instagram actually
has very strong policies you know as
we've talked about on the show before to
try to identify offensive harmful
content to take it down to knock people
off those platforms of all the social
media companies Instagram probably has
the strongest policies one of the most
interesting questions I think is whether
the social media policies should work
harder to kind of algorithm ly identify
this stuff and then not delete it but
try to shift user behavior so one of the
things that Google has built is when
they identify somebody searching for
jihadist content they have the capacity
to show them to counter radicalization
content could you do the same thing for
people who show attributes of possible
shooters I don't know but it's an
interesting question all right Nick
Thompson we have to leave it there thank
you very much for joining us from
California today